Welcome to the debate.
In the book, The Master and the Disciple by Jafar Ibn Mansour, we encounter a pretty profound crisis.
How do you win a debate against the opposing community's greatest scholar by emptying him rather than arguing with him?
The cup must be emptied before it can be filled.
And well, the position I hold today defends the framework of that visiting scholar.
I approach this encounter from the belief that when a person has built a rigorous foundation of logical deduction,
their immense learning inherently qualifies them to weigh any claim.
They do not need to simply discard their intellectual framework to recognize the truth.
If an argument is genuinely superior, a highly developed logical system will recognize it and adapt.
I understand why you defend his intellectual foundation, I really do, but I am representing the methodology of the young teacher in this encounter.
My position is that intellectual demolition is not just an alternative teaching method.
It is an absolute spiritual necessity.
An absolute necessity.
Yes.
When a scholar reaches that highest level of eminence, their certainty becomes a polished surface on which nothing new can land.
Intellectual accumulation alone is fundamentally insufficient for truth.
Before any new understanding can take root, the existing structure of assumptions must be completely dismantled.
But we have to recognize what you are asking.
him to give up here.
The visiting scholar is not some arrogant novice.
No, of course not.
He is the most celebrated debater of his time.
He arrives having repented of his sins, having repaid his debts, and operating completely under the standard of justice.
He has constructed a rigorous system of rational thought.
The visiting scholar believes, quite rationally, that his vast learning equips him to weigh any argument presented to him.
you are arguing that his very framework is the barrier.
But without that framework, how does anyone evaluate what is true and what is false?
Well, his framework is precisely the barrier because it dictates the boundaries of what he is willing to accept as possible.
He evaluates everything against what he already knows.
Naturally.
Yeah, but if a new truth does not fit his existing intellectual structure, it just bounces off that polished surface.
And this is why the opening move of this entire encounter happens before the formal debate even begins.
It starts at the threshold.
You mean the arrival at the house?
Exactly.
The visiting scholar arrives and asks the host after the young teacher.
He is met by the father at the door who does not give a straightforward factual answer.
Instead, the father issues a riddle.
Today, the young teacher is my father and I am his son and he is with his lord.
And the visiting scholar's reaction to this is completely natural, which actually validates the strength of his logical framework.
How so?
Well, he takes the natural reading of those words.
He is a master of syntax.
When he hears the phrase, with his Lord, he immediately assumes death, because that is the linguistic standard of his community.
Yeah, the standard idiom.
Exactly.
Assuming the young teacher has died, he respectfully recites the verse for the deceased chapter, 2, verse 156.
He is operating perfectly within the bounds of theological etiquette.
He takes the data provided, processes it through his extensive knowledge, and produces the correct theological response.
He produces the correct response for his own paradigm, sure, but his assumption is immediately corrected.
The father gathers the riddle and entirely refuses the visitor's interpretation.
He states clearly that the young teacher is not dead, nor will he ever die.
Indeed, he abides with Allah for all eternity.
See, I do not buy that yet.
Let me tell you why.
Isn't this demolition just humiliation dressed up as pedagogy?
Humiliation?
No.
Well, the visiting scholar is given a riddle specifically designed to be misunderstood, only to be publicly corrected by his host.
It feels less like profound spiritual instruction and more like a cheap intellectual trap meant to disorient him.
I have to disagree.
If the young teacher possesses a superior truth, why not simply invite the visitor in, sit down and present a superior logical argument?
Why play games at the door?
It is not a game and it is not cruelty.
It is a structural necessity for what must follow.
You are still treating the visiting scholar's mind as simply open to receiving new information, but we established that his certainty is a polished surface.
Yes, but.
The riddle at the door is designed to initiate the first crack in that surface.
Consider the three perplexities embedded in that single sentence.
The son has become the father.
The mortal lives forever.
The Lord exists on earth with a servant.
It is entirely disorienting.
Precisely.
Before the visitor has even stepped through the inner door, he has been explicitly told that he is entering a house where the hierarchies of the physical world have been entirely rearranged.
So the disarmament must precede the dialogue.
You are arguing that he must be shown his mastery of external syntax simply does not apply to internal realities.
Otherwise, he will try to debate the internal realities using external rules.
Exactly.
The greatest scholar of his community is being asked to meet a young man who
to the very household that produced him, operates as the father.
The riddle prepares the visitor for what is about to happen, though he does not yet realize how completely his framework is about to be dismantled.
This sets a very tense stage for the actual meeting.
The narrative brings them together and the young teacher receives the visitor with perfect courtesy.
This profound etiquette governs the tone of the entire encounter.
There is no hostility.
The young teacher prays that Allah will open the ears of their hearts, signaling the only type of opening this specific debate will rely upon.
But rather than presenting A theological thesis for the master debater to attack, the young teacher asks a highly disarming question.
He asks, which of three kinds of seeker are you?
Exactly.
And he outlines these three categories with absolute clarity.
Are you the one who already knows, the one beginning to know, or the one who desires to know but does not yet?
These are not arbitrary divisions invented for the moment.
Yeah, they have a deep history.
The first is the divine scholar, the one who seeks the dead to give them life.
The classical texts refer to this rank as Alim al-Rabbani, a designation of immense spiritual weight.
The second is the learner on the path of salvation.
This mutallam has some knowledge already and seeks its final, actualized stage.
And the third.
Finally, there is the beginner, the ignorant who recognizes only his own need.
The structure of these three categories is deeply rooted in the broader tradition.
It echoes a very specific saying recorded in the canonical compilation of sermons.
The book Naj al-Balaga contains this exact structure, originating from Commander of the Faithful, peace be upon him.
He divides humanity into three, the divine scholar, the learner upon the path of salvation, and the rabble who bend with every wind.
The young teacher is utilizing a shared intellectual inheritance.
He places the visiting scholar inside a hierarchy he already recognizes and forces him to locate himself.
And the location he chooses is the pivot of the entire encounter.
The visiting scholar has read more books than his entire community combined.
He is the master debater, yet facing the clarity of those 3 categories, he places himself in the third category.
He names himself the beginner.
It is an astonishing concession.
He has been a scholar his entire life, yet he confesses he has never actually asked himself what kind of seeking he was doing.
That confession is the move that opens the door.
The source steps back here and explicitly names the vital principle of debate the young teacher is applying.
The technical term for this spiritual methodology is demolition.
Right, Kasra?
Yes, the young teacher is performing the specific work of the mukasar.
I understand the mechanics of what he is doing, but how is this different from any teacher telling a student to drop their assumptions?
Every rhetoric professor, every philosophy
instructor asks their students to set aside their preconceived notions before learning a new paradigm.
It goes much deeper than that.
What makes this specific technique of demolition anything more than standard pedagogical protocol?
Is fundamentally different because of the depth of the void it demands.
A professor asking a student to drop their assumptions is facilitating an intellectual exercise.
It is asking the student to temporarily adopt a new lens for the sake of an argument.
Okay.
What the young teacher is doing is not a temporary suspension of belief.
It is the absolute necessity of the void.
It is a spiritual dismantling.
The young teacher is not asking the visiting scholar to pretend he does not know.
He is forcing him to realize the complete inadequacy of his entire life's accumulation.
The cup must be emptied before it can be filled.
He is exposing that the scholar's vast library of knowledge has not actually moved him an inch closer to the divine reality he claims to study.
Try to refill his cup with more of the same material.
The young teacher draws a critical, devastating distinction between two ways of interacting with truth.
The difference between Elm and Merifa.
Yes, there is a profound difference between merely knowing and truly understanding.
The first belongs to the knower.
The Alim acquires data, memorizes doctrines, and deploys them in arguments.
It functions purely as a report.
The transmission of something one has heard, what the texts call Khabar.
Exactly.
But true understanding is direct seeing.
It is an experience of Ayin.
It belongs entirely to the Gnostic.
The adiv does not merely hold information.
They experience a completely different reality.
Knowing versus really knowing.
You are taking a standard cognitive function and attaching A dramatic emotional intensifier to it.
Is not just an emotional intensifier.
Why does an emotional intensity validate the truth of a claim more than rigorous logical deduction?
Because rigorous logical deduction, when detached from the internal state of the soul, produces sterility.
requires no transformation of character.
The young teacher uses the reality of heaven and hell to illustrate this, and the example is devastating.
He points out that the knower is completely aware that heaven and hell exist.
That awareness stays at the level of information.
It can be cited in a conversation.
It can be turned into a brilliant theological treatise.
It can be used to win a debate.
It is stored safely in the head.
Sure.
But the Gnostic has a deep, visceral realization of what heaven means and a powerful longing to reach it, alongside an absolute terror of hell.
So they both possess the exact same words, heaven and hell, but the words generate 2 entirely different lives.
Exactly.
In one life, the words are stored facts.
In the other, the words generate a burning in the chest that will not let the body sit still.
True understanding is when a person knows by their own intellect that they cannot find the answers themselves.
Their heart becomes completely constricted by their ignorance, and their only hope of freedom is to learn.
They have felt the ignorance in their own bones.
The constriction of the heart is the actual entry into the search.
But relying on a bodily reality or a burning in the chest is incredibly dangerous.
I maintain my reservation here.
Without the anchor of rigorous logical deduction, an intense emotional experience could lead someone to absolute falsehood just as easily as to the truth.
I see your point.
If we abandon the logical framework entirely, we lose the ability to verify if the heat in our heart is guiding us correctly or simply manipulating us.
Many operate at the level of mere knowledge their whole lives specifically because it is safe.
It is verifiable.
It is safe, but it is ultimately dead.
This distinction between mere knowledge and transformative seeing has classical roots that long predate this specific debate.
We see it in chapter 39, verse 9, which asks pointedly, are those who know equal to those who do not know?
The verse opens a massive gap between 2 distinct states of the soul, treating the difference as two unequal weights, not merely between fuller and emptier minds.
We do see this sharpened in the text known as Misbah al-Sharia, or the lamp of the sacred law.
The text defines knowledge not as much narration, but as a light that Allah casts into the heart of whomever He wills.
Yes.
The first half of that concept refuses to identify true understanding with the recitation of reports.
The second-half identifies it with an act of God on the heart of the seeker, moving it out of the realm of pure human cognition.
And the exact same line is drawn centuries later in Ihya Ulum al-Din, the revival of the religious sciences.
In that text, the later scholar warns the student explicitly.
He states that the scholar who has only accumulated reports is a profound danger to himself.
Only the transformed one is safe.
Exactly.
The one who has been transformed by what he reports is the only one safe to imitate.
The burning in the chest that the young teacher just named is the exact mark used to tell the two apart from the outside.
The knower possesses facts about a fire, but the Gnostic feels the heat of the flames.
So the knower's facts demand nothing of his soul.
He can be a master debater and still be spiritually void.
That is the tragedy of it.
The desperation of the Gnostic is the proof that the reality of the concept has finally penetrated the soul.
I see the weight of the young teacher's argument and the visiting scholar in the narrative sees it too.
He finally realizes that despite reading more books than anyone in his community, he holds only reports.
He confesses that he found that intense neediness in his own soul.
He admits, in front of his companions who have come with him on the standard of justice, that the words his community has been carrying for centuries can be carried in two entirely different ways, and he is now ready to ask which way he has been carrying them.
He has been demolished completely.
He came to the door full, but the young teacher successfully emptied him.
The polished surface has been thoroughly shattered.
He was met at the threshold by a riddle that rearranged every hierarchy he carried with him.
He was asked which of three kinds of seeker he was and willingly placed himself among the beginners.
He was given the critical distinction between rapport and vision and confessed that the intense neediness was the longing he himself had been carrying without ever knowing its name.
While the young teacher's pedagogy is undeniably effective here, I must point out a crucial closing caution from the source itself.
The visiting scholar expresses a sudden hope that disputation might be avoided entirely if truth simply shows itself.
Having been demolished, he wants the new truth immediately.
Of course, the rush to refill.
But the young teacher strongly cautions against rushing the rebuilding.
He says that every knowledge for which the hearts of students have not first been purified by proper argument will not flourish.
The demolition creates the space, but the space must still be treated with profound care.
Exactly.
Every prepared ground must be broken before a seed can grow.
The argument is the preparing.
The demolition has been the digging.
The seed cannot be planted before the ground is completely ready.
While I still maintain that abandoning logical frameworks carries immense risk, I can see that the rigorous logic alone could never have broken the soil of his certainty.
The demolition is the vital work itself.
The cup must be emptied before it can be filled, which leaves us with a question to carry forward, drawn directly from this extraordinary encounter.
What is it?
Look inward at the structure of your own certainties.
Which of the three kinds of seeker are you?
And what borrowed certainty would have to be broken this week for the next thing to land?